[Music]
this episode and others like it are made
possible by the generous support of my
patrons on patreon if you'd like to help
me make more political content consider
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
second thought some viewers may find the
following content disturbing viewer
discretion advised I think America must
see that riots do not develop out of
thin air
certain conditions continue to exist in
our society which must be condemned as
vigorously as we condemn riots then the
final analysis a riot is the language of
the unheard what is it that America has
failed to hear it has failed to hear
that the plight of the Negro poor has
worsened over the last few years has
failed to hear that the promises of
freedom and justice have not been met
and it has failed to hear that large
segments of white society are more
concerned about tranquility and the
status quo than about justice equality
and humanity so on a real sense our
nation some of the riots are caused by
our nation's winters of delay as long as
America holds forms justice we stand in
the position of having these recurrences
of violence and riots over and over
again social justice and progress are
the absolute guarantee
[Music]
on May 25th 2020 a 46 year old black man
named George Floyd was murdered by the
Minneapolis Police Floyd had recently
lost his job as a result of the
Minnesota stay at home order and was
accused of using a counterfeit $20 bill
at a grocery store in response the
police handcuffed him pinned him to the
ground and officer derrick shavon knelt
on Floyd's neck for 8 minutes and 46
seconds during that time Floyd pleaded
for them to stop he said he couldn't
breathe
that he was in pain he called out for
his mother we can see one of the
officers Lane check Floyd's pulse
sometime after he's become unresponsive
according to the complaint against
Derrick shavon Lane asked him twice
whether they should roll Floyd onto his
side both times shop and said no and
kept pressing his knee into the man's
neck a move banned by most police
departments even after an ambulance
arrives and the medic checks Floyd's
pulse again
shavon stays where he is it's only when
the EMTs tell him to get off that he
finally does so after almost nine
minutes Floyd is pronounced dead at a
nearby hospital shortly after four days
later on May 29th
shavon is charged with manslaughter and
third degree murder as of writing the
script for this video on June 1st 2020
the three other officers involved have
yet to be charged but what had to happen
in those four days between the murder of
George Floyd and the charges against
shavon and what has happened since is
what really matters in this video we're
going to take a good hard look at the
state of police brutality and systemic
racism in the United States before we
begin let me just say by the time this
video is uploaded things will have
changed the past six days have been
incredibly tumultuous and no one has
been able to predict what will happen
next I will explain the situation to the
best of my ability based on the material
I have available as of June 1st to 2020
let's get some background details out of
the way first in the aftermath of George
Floyd's murder the site of his arrest
was turned into a memorial through May
26th from there a crowd began to gather
growing to hundreds of people and
eventually marching to the Minneapolis
police's 3rd precinct where shavon and
the others were stationed since that day
protests against police brutality have
erupted all over the United States in
over a hundred cities as well as in
places like England Germany and New
Zealand as police took to the streets in
riot gear to disperse
the protesters more people became
involved and as millions around the
country watched footage of cops lobbing
tear gas into crowds shooting protesters
with rubber bullets even brutalizing and
arresting the reporters covering the
events support for the protests grew
eventually in what should be considered
an historic event protestors managed to
capture and burn the third precinct on
May 28th predictably as the protests
grew we began to hear the usual voices
condemning them yet as we've seen time
and again what began as peaceful
protesting ended up in a very
counterproductive and even criminal
place but we cannot allow the righteous
cries and peaceful protesters to be
drown out by an angry mob a weekend of
unrest amid calls for change and a plea
for peace here's the thing for these
people there's no right way for people
of color to protest the one saying
destruction of property makes them look
bad are the same ones who called Colin
Kaepernick a traitor and a son of a
[__] for kneeling quietly during the
anthem if they're quiet they're
disrespectful and should just work
harder if they're loud they're hurting
their own image if the protests are
widespread and organic they're incapable
of organizing if they're organized and
set clear demands they're led by outside
agitators there will never be a protest
of any sort that is acceptable for those
in power and those who benefit from the
status quo any real expression of anger
will be smeared and condemned what
happens when quiet respectful protests
are ignored this is what happens
patience runs out frankly it's
remarkable the restraint the black
community has shown over the years
decades of asking please stop killing us
fell on deaf ears and now the police are
facing the righteous anger of the entire
country and even huge crowds in other
countries the people condemning riots
are quick to quote Martin Luther King
but their version is a whitewash shell
of what dr. King really stood for let's
take a quick look at the civil rights
movement after Rosa Parks was arrested
for refusing to give up her seat to a
white person the n-double-a-cp chose
King to lead the Montgomery bus boycott
with the goal of desegregating public
transportation King quickly became the
face of the civil rights movement
advocating civil disobedience and
nonviolent protests he led marches for
freedom and equality gave brilliant
speeches and was a voice for those who
had long been considered second-class
citizens for his actions he was jailed
over 20 times
his house was bombed he faced constant
death threats from white supremacists
and even received a letter from the FBI
suggesting he should kill himself or
they would release supposedly
incriminating tapes of him but King was
undeterred between 1957 and 1968 he
travelled over six million miles led
countless protests and delivered over
2,000 speeches for the cause of equality
the people today who invoke the name of
Martin Luther King for his non-violence
choose to disregard one critical aspect
of the civil rights movement the
peaceful protesters were brutalized by
the police for the crime of wanting to
be considered a human being
police viciously attacked King and his
fellow marchers again King was
undeterred he kept marching kept
protesting finally after intense
pressure from the black community and
their allies President Lyndon Johnson
signed the Civil Rights Act of 1964 and
the Voting Act of 1965 but the signing
of these acts did not erase America's
hatred towards the black community good
evening the Reverend dr. Martin Luther
King 39 years old and a Nobel Peace
Prize winner and the leader of the
nonviolent civil rights movement in the
United States was assassinated in
Memphis tonight a sniper's bullet cut
down dr. King as he stood in a hotel
balcony in Memphis the assassin was
later apprehended and it's likely that
he had been working with the FBI we may
never know for certain but it definitely
aligns with their previous threats when
Martin Luther King died he had a 75%
disapproval rating in the United States
it was only after his death that the
white people of America could rewrite
his story and make him a figurehead for
obedience
taking his practice of non-violence and
twisting it to mean ever organizing
against your oppressors they paint him
as a docile man who only said nice
things that everyone agreed with and
they choose to leave out the fact that
he was an outspoken opponent of
capitalism American hypocrisy poverty
militarism and racism but let's talk
about non-violence for a minute critics
of the recent riots have said that the
protestors are violent that looting a
target is violent that burning in Arby's
is violent destruction of inanimate
buildings is not violence killing people
is violence assaulting protesters and
driving police cruisers into crowds is
violence the protesters haven't killed
anyone you'd be hard-pressed to find
evidence of a protester even taking a
swing at a cop in some instances they've
even protected police officers who got
separated from their pack non-violence
is a tactic if for example the crowds
to destroy say saber security equipment
which manufactures pepper spray for the
police and is located at 7:47 Sun Park
Drive in Fenton Missouri that would be
furthering the cause of non-violence
because they're removing part of the
means by which violence is done to the
people those decrying violence aren't
concerned with police brutality but
expect you to shed a tear over looting a
target as a totally unrelated side note
the largest source of theft by far is
wage theft by corporations to the tune
of forty billion dollars a year stolen
from workers in the form of overtime
violations minimum wage violations and
rest break and off-the-clock violations
so excuse me if I don't care that people
are taking back a little of what they're
owed but now we get to the real heart of
the matter and again I want to warn
viewers that you may find this content
disturbing we need to talk about police
brutality militarization and white
supremacy since the beginning of the
uprising the cops have shown us exactly
who they are riot gear tasers tear gas
pepper spray vicious beatings slashing
of tires rubber bullets armored trucks
the police in response to a protest
against police brutality decided to act
even more brutally towards the people
they're supposed to protect and serve
but what's even more disgusting than
their actions among the crowds is how
they choose to act when they think no
one is looking
cops wearing plain clothes or disguises
some even in their full riot gear have
been breaking windows leaving piles of
bricks lying around and parking cruisers
in high-traffic areas with firearms
inside all of these actions are to try
to incite the crowds to become violent
and thereby give the police more
justification in killing people
the really disheartening thing is when
you begin to realize that the police are
enjoying this they've been caught on
camera laughing about violently
assaulting people one was caught
throwing up a white power sign this is
all pretty damning but there will still
be people who say it's just a few bad
apples the funny thing is that no one
seems to remember the rest of that
expression one bad apple spoils the
bunch that holds especially true with
people in a position of power if you
have a thousand good cops and ten bad
cops and the thousand good cops don't
turn in the ten bad ones you have a
thousand and ten bad cops but the thing
is the police haven't given us any
evidence that there are any good cops at
all over the last few days
pictures have begun to circulate of cops
taking a knee near protesters this has
garnered them some support but in every
case either immediately before or after
the cops assaulted or
/ sprayed the protesters this is called
Coppa ganda it's a PR stunt if they
really cared they would have taken any
years ago we're at least in the
immediate aftermath of Floyd's murder
but they didn't instead they pretend to
care and then viciously attack everyone
in the area luckily even though the
police are turning off their body cams
there are plenty of video cameras at the
protests the police can't fake their way
out of their inexcusable behavior
speaking of video cameras let's talk
about how the police have treated the
press during the uprising prime minister
Scott Morrison has taken action after a
seven news crew was assaulted by u.s.
police during protests in Washington DC
this morning reporter Amelia brace and
her cameraman were attacked during a
live on-air report we are live on the
air at the moment this is the four of us
we are one team
I'm sorry okay do you mind telling me
why I'm under arrest sir
as you've probably already seen on the
news it's hideous reporters from many
different outlets have been assaulted
their gear destroyed and some have even
been arrested while live on the air
there is no possible way the police
didn't realize there the press they have
giant lights tripods and cameras
not to mention microphones and press
badges the fact that everyone from Fox
News to CNN to countless independent
outlets have been attacked should show
you this isn't a partisan issue it's a
police state issue the cops don't want
their actions to be broadcast and
they'll go to ridiculous
counterproductive ends to try to keep it
from happening including arresting
reporters while their cameras are
rolling there's a thread on Twitter
that's currently over 90 tweets long
documenting instances of police
brutality against the press specifically
and it's shocking pushed over shot with
rubber bullets beaten with batons gassed
even pepper sprayed while displaying
their press credentials there is no
excuse none for the police to deny the
press their rights to cover events as
they unfold and certainly not to
violently assault them while they try to
do their jobs a free press is essential
to a healthy democracy and what we're
seeing should be a wake-up call
okay
I'm blessed
but the police aren't the only ones
attempting to maim or kill protesters
white supremacists armed with guns have
started to show up and threaten
protesters surely they're being arrested
right
this man had his rifle pointed at
demonstrators and all he got was a quiet
chat with a cop who sent him on his way
unarmed protesters get beaten armed
white supremacists get to walk away
after threatening to kill people I don't
think it's a stretch to say that maybe
there's a connection when cops throw up
white power signs and white vigilantes
get a friendly talk instead of being
tased and arrested in Detroit on May
30th an SUV pulled up to a crowd and
someone inside opened fire on protesters
killing a 19 year old before fleeing the
scene they have not been apprehended
another man 22 year old James Scurlock
was murdered by a white supremacist
business owner who had been yelling
racial slurs at protesters all night he
shot Scurlock twice in the neck the City
of Omaha announced they will not bring
charges against him these killers are
the same people who will yell all lives
matter at people of color marching for
justice it would be easy for me to say
that the slogan all lives matter is a
racist dog whistle and leave it at that
because well
but I want to believe there are people
out there who aren't violent racists and
truly don't understand so I'll try
something else
imagine you've taken your beautiful
family to the beach Kayden Braden and
Breeden's Li are happy building a
sandcastle
but broccoli is drowning out in the
water if your response is to shake your
head at broccoli and say all lives
matter that makes you a bad parent
now apply that line of thought to what
we're seeing today people of color are
killed by the police at a much much
higher rate than other groups if the
phrase black lives matter bothers you
please consider why you feel that way
perpetrators aside we need to take a
look at the weapons the police are using
to assault protesters let's start with
teargas
teargas is a chemical weapon that causes
temporary blindness severe eye and
respiratory pain skin irritation and
bleeding if you heard the words chemical
weapon and thought wait aren't those
banned yes yes they are in war but
apparently it's perfectly acceptable to
use them on your own citizens
you'd think such an extreme option would
be saved as a last resort but we've seen
cops use it as the first offensive
against protesters in recent days rubber
bullets are one of the most common ways
the police have been harming protesters
okay but it's rubber right how bad can
it be well judging by the fact that
they're considered a less lethal round
instead of a non-lethal round and you're
supposed to fire them at the ground to
bounce them at your target not fire at
people directly that should give you a
pretty good idea these things can and do
kill and surprise surprise cops have
been firing them directly at people at
least one person has been permanently
blinded in one eye after being hit in
the face with a rubber bullet at best
these things hurt like hell and leave a
nasty bruise at worst they can tear a
chunk out of your face blind you or even
kill you on the spot then of course
there are Tasers batons flashbang
grenades horses apparently car doors and
the whole damn vehicle but the most
dangerous tool in the police Arsenal is
the officer himself the police have
shown that they have exactly zero
restraint they've kicked people while
they're down and blinded slashed tires
tased the passengers and dragged them
out of the car they've maced people who
were cooperating shoved one woman to the
ground so hard she had a seizure pushed
over an old man walking with a cane and
launched full-out assaults on peacefully
assembled citizens yes the police need
to be demilitarized there's
clear connection between the money spent
on military grade equipment and violence
against citizens but demilitarization
alone won't solve the problem the police
are the problem
they're never held accountable without
massive pressure from the people and
even then they often get released on
bail or just assigned to a new station a
couple towns over our politicians have
been silent at best or actively
encouraging of racist violence in the
case of the President and some other
extremists in government the presumptive
Democratic nominee has said maybe we can
shoot them in the leg instead what kind
of a solution is that the deadly
combination of military police and white
supremacy has rotted the police
apparatus to the core when armed white
protesters can show up to a government
building threatened the lawmakers and no
one gets arrested tased or beaten but
black people are murdered for doing
nothing at all you cannot reach any
conclusion other than that there are two
Americas one for the white people and
those in power and one for everyone else
when cops are throwing up white power
signs and laughing about brutalizing the
people they're supposed to protect and
serve you have to realize that the
system is broken we've already seen
deaths in this uprising white
supremacist murderers have killed people
or attempted to do so on camera and they
walk away the protesters have not killed
anyone we have to reject the mainstream
media's framing of the uprising the
protesters are not the violent ones the
police are they instigate the
confrontations every time they arrest
and assault journalists they drive cars
into crowds of people for God's sake
what the media won't show you is the
scenes of peaceful protests the kind
they claim to want scenes of solidarity
and joy in the face of oppression and
tragedy protesters dancing together
cooking meals for those in need
offering medical attention to their
neighbors injured by the police on
multiple occasions the police have
rolled up and destroyed these supply
stations even firing rubber bullets at
medics taking care of the injured shot
in the leg with a rubber bullet he was
bleeding so much each other I was
helping him I was cutting his pants I
was trying to help him was trying to
look at the wound and and they came up
and they say were shooting right at us
he grabbed a garbage can to hold that
hold it over me so I wouldn't get hurt
and I told him I wouldn't leave him and
I did and I feel so bad I couldn't they
were shooting I was
they didn't care they didn't care that
he was hurt but the people have not been
deterred they come back reorganize and
fight to defend their communities and
demand a better life for their children
lawyers have offered to represent those
arrested in the protest for free mutual
aid and bail funds are being flooded
with donations from all over the country
people are bringing food water and
medical supplies to sustain the
protesters if you'd like to help there
will be links in the description for
funds to contribute to we should be
ashamed and infuriated that our country
has chosen to violently suppress its own
people rather than hold the police
accountable for their actions and it's
not over yet this will get worse now
that the National Guard has been called
into several states and are armed with
live ammunition I can only pray that by
the time this video goes live the state
will not have murdered crowds of
civilians the police are in the wrong
they are the problem to the protesters
standing up against centuries of
injustice the eyes of the world are upon
you you have the support of people from
all walks of life of all colors and
creeds from countries around the world
and right here at home there will be
opposition from those who benefit from
the status quo but you have the right to
have a say in your future and we're
proud of you for standing against
systemic racism and police brutality we
stand in solidarity with your efforts
and join you in the hope that one day
soon we can build a better world
if you enjoyed this video and you'd like
to see more like it consider subscribing
to stay up to date with my latest
episodes if you hated it go ahead and
drop a thumbs down and if you really
want to help support my channel I
recently started a patreon which you can
find at patreon.com slash second thought
you can check out my previous episodes
by clicking the links on your screen
thanks for watching and I'll see you
next week